my name is Daniel cook so before I even
get started into my talk I just wanted
to who is at the talk earlier this
afternoon at McKinley on forecasting
automation robustly okay so some of you
guys gave to talk thank you okay because
it turns out why talk tax like highly
related to their talk so I'll probably
be referencing their talk a few times
today on the fly here so see how that
goes but uh yeah totally unplanned but
it was exciting I enjoyed their talk
okay so today I'll be talking about
forecasting time series data
specifically with the tick stack explain
what that is and at scale and I'll
explain what I mean by AB scale so like
I said I'm a tango cook I worked for a
company called influx data and we build
a set of open source products that we
call the tick stack and there are a time
series data processing platform
so hence timeseriesforecasting time
series products this is great so that
will just jump right in so so why am I
here a couple months ago Facebook
released their profit algorithm that
these guys talked a little bit about
previously and I've read up but I was
like ah that's interesting that's kind
of fun so I tried it out and had a good
experience so I'm here to show that with
you and to see how it works out so an
overview what we'll be talking about
today first let's give a quick review of
what I mean when I say time series data
forecasting really simple and then we'll
talk about the challenges of scale and
what I mean by when I say scale and then
we'll introduce and a little bit of
depth the Facebook profit algorithm and
that procedure and how that works and
then then the majority of talk will be
focused on an example walk through an
experiment I did using their algorithm a
net procedure and how that turned out
for me on some example data and then
we'll present some learnings and then
wrap up great
so what is timeseriesforecasting well
assuming that the past has any relation
on the future we can predict future
values based off past values and so the
the idea there is you develop a model
doesn't matter what the model is great
develop a model that says based on these
past values what should my future values
be and so that's what I mean we say time
series data forecast
then you need to compute the accuracy
and the earlier talk give us a nice huge
list of a dozen different metrics that
you can use to compute the accuracy of
your time to use metric today we'll just
focus on one the the ma PE mean absolute
percentage error but you could switch it
out for any of the others that I talked
about today and then finally another
method is is to use baseline models and
to compare the your predicted model
against other models that are more
simple to make sure that your baseline
model hasn't just gone totally crazy and
done something weird okay so there you
go simple hand-drawing
time series data on the Left you've got
the red line which is your raw data and
then you predict ah it's going to do
something like the blue line right and
then the black tick represents the
current time and then and then later
real time passes and then you actually
get the raw data for the data that you
predict it and they overlap because they
were for the same period of time and
then you compare them and you say well
how good were they right and this is
where there's multiple different metrics
so that the ma PE metric is basically
you take the percentage error between
those and you take the mean across that
entire interval and you get a number
between zero and one and zero means you
predicted it perfectly because you had
zero error and one means that the
relative values was a hundred percent
off and you can even go above one
actually if you get really really bad
air will actually see an example of that
today okay so what are the challenges of
forecasting a scale it's actually simple
it takes a lot of time to get a model to
work right so most the time when you put
a model in production it's the model
that's doing something awesome and you
can spend a lot of time tuning it and
optimizing it and making that model work
for you in this case we have lots and
lots of models and so we can't spend
time each of the models we have to make
sure that on a big scale that all the
models individually they're working well
but we don't have time to sit there and
babysit each one so we need to design a
workflow and a system where we can
minimize or in fact eliminate the time
we spend on any of the models
great so this is where Facebook's
profit procedure comes in and they talk
about they today's talk isn't just about
the technology it's also about the
people involved where the people the
teams and the interactions and how
communication happens and a workflow so
that the communication is effective and
efficient so the Facebook algorithm
Spacek the Facebook paper called profit
didn't just introduce a model or an
algorithm it also introduced this
workflow or this procedure to go with it
so we'll talk about that here
so first what was the algorithm it's
actually really simple and it was
intentionally very simple it was a
generative general additive model I call
it basically you just your predicted
value is why they're on the left of this
this graph here and this equation and
then you had three terms and you just
add them together and those terms equal
your predicted value okay so what are
those three terms the first term of the
growth term and it just kind of predicts
the overall trend up or down of your of
whatever series you're forecasting the
second term of the seasonality term so
the the domain in which this algorithm
tends to work well our business metrics
so for example things that have daily
cycles or weekly cycles or monthly or
yearly cycles these kinds of seasonal
cycles in them and so the seasonality
term would learn about those things and
then lastly you could add in a holiday
term which would say hey July 1st
everybody or July 4th quasi first July
4th everybody shooting out fireworks and
nobody's doing any work and so we could
expect something different on that day
and so you can account for those kinds
of things ok so that was the model the
algorithm so what's the workflow and so
Facebook labeled it analyst in the loop
or basically put the analyst in there
who's someone who understands basic
statistics but is it necessarily
statistician and and who isn't
necessarily a DevOps guy either who's
running around and setting up servers
and code
it's just someone understands the domain
of the data and wants to and wants to
make sure that the models are working
well so this four step cycle or workflow
at first you create a model and so in
this case creating a profit model right
modeling based off profit algorithm and
then second you evaluate that model
based on some metric like I repeated
we're going to use the the map MFE
metrics today then at the bottom you
surface all of the forecasts that have
problems so we'll define what they have
problems that means a minute but you
surface them and you bring them forward
so that you know that those are the ones
you need to spend time on as opposed to
all and then you visually inspect the
model and you look at it and go off this
is what's wrong with it and then you fix
it and then you get back to the top so
the analyst need only participate in
these purple on steps these green steps
are fully automated and they can happen
on in the background
do not touch upon I think about them
they just run and so the analysts just
simply sit there and spend their time
working through the problematic models
fixing them and tuning them and
basically gets this nice workflow where
the problem surface on their own and
they can spend time just whacking them
all and it sounds boring but it's a lot
better than not knowing where the mole
is thwack horrible analogy shouldn't
wait data okay great so now we're going
to jump right into the example work
through the data before I do that or any
any questions starting off I'm right now
I kinda like this a little bit more
interactive so if you've got questions
okay great yes great so what am i
Canadian no sorry
I mean okay hi I'm not Canadian nope oh
okay oh it's my first note that was just
I've no idea what that was yeah great so
for this example I went and got a
dataset that's how we plan to look at so
I went to github and I found an awesome
Python most you guys too often must
forget where people I compiled these
lists of awesome things and so there's
an awesome Python list out there it's
got about 400 Python projects listed in
there under different categories for
different things and I wouldn't I
grabbed their gap stars and so we can
meaning you get as a relative proxy for
popularity of the project and it's a
nice time series data so we're gonna
play with it so the cool thing about
grabbing awesome lists as opposed to
just grabbing the top 100 or 400 repos
was it was at the top right so in this
list it's a very very heterogeneous list
of projects that do very different
things and and that's going to be
important a minute so some of these
projects are really small might there's
a dozen of these projects that only have
30 stars but they're on this awesome
list because they're awesome somehow but
only sort of people agree and then
there's some really large projects on
this list as well some projects that
have 30,000 plus stars and and then very
large and then these projects range from
very different use cases some of them
are really simple like CLI tools they're
like nothing to do with data science and
they're just happening written Python
and then some of them are like type I
and then these other like important
numpy and important Python projects
important to us and so they're very very
diverse so my point in pointing out the
diversity of these projects is that they
that you can expect different growth
patterns on these projects right the
time series growth on each of these
projects is not going to be the same
they're going to have different
characteristics they're going to be
unique in their own way and so we're
going to learn about and then likely
it's somewhere we have new and old
projects have some projects that were
there and like day one of github
and so they have dates I'll be back 2008
some of them are started earlier this
year and so only have a few months of
data so we've got this this very
heterogeneous set of projects but then
the data is all the same in that it's
just a simple growing curve of stars
over time ok so what's our goals of the
example well we want to forecast the
future stars of these projects for all
400 of these repositories and get out
and we want to be able to fix any
forecast that we set up initially that
are broken are just really bad and we
want to do it in a repeatable manner
such that this cost very little overhead
very little time and resources on an
analyst or developer so that you can you
can do this as scale right and 400s
pretty small right but the idea here is
you know these could be different
communities right so the example the
Facebook uses is they have lots of
communities think you have Facebook like
different groups and things like this
they have each one of those has its own
growth and things like that and so
they're managing many many many of these
that's a and I little insight of how
this could be used on a bigger scale ok
so to do this in a scalable manner we
need a nice platform or be nice to have
a nice platform so is where the tick's
tech comes in ok so let's take a minute
here and then about six taxes so first
tick is an acronym for TSE k and for the
four products that make up the stack so
telegraph is this first piece
it's a over here and telegraph the tiger
it's pretty awesome and telegraph is a
collection agent so the idea here is
it's the thing that goes and gets your
data we're not using it in this example
per se just because I already collected
800 just by scraping the the gab api's
but in a more real-time environment you
need a way to kind of ingest your data
in a real-time way and that's what
Telegraph can do for you okay so then
the next piece in the stack is in flux
DB and that's the database that stores
the time series data it's optimized for
storing time series data and and it has
a sequel like query interface so that
you can start your data in query back
out
do kinds of operations that you
typically do on time aggregation
selections etcetera etcetera okay so
then the next piece is cronograph which
is up here choreographed dress run the
contractor up today he's pretty often
this is a visualization engine to detect
the sec so it allows you to visualize
graph your data build it's basically the
GUI for the rest of the stack and so
that's what crew graph does and then
last is capacitor I'm actually the
developer of capacitor and it's the
real-time processing engine on the data
so the database allows you to write the
data and in query back out with some
basic aggregations when you want to
start running machine learning models or
other complex things on your data that's
when you're bringing capacitor to be
able to do all this processing so an
analogy it is very rough but probably
doesn't like a mole one but capacitors
kind of like spark Apache spark in this
sense specifically built obviously for
the time series use case and for this
for this spec okay so that's the take
stack we're going to use it today to
model all these 400 gave repos and
forecast they're stars okay so how are
we going to do that
first we just need to store the data in
flux to be that was relatively
straightforward downloaded it well
relatively meaning all the data cleaning
like takes a little while but download
all the data from gap API rejigger it
stored in flux to be at the database so
now in the database we have a set of
timestamps for when a user signed
starred the repo and then and then
github terminal or an implicit
terminology we've tagged that data with
which repository that's that star with
four tag just means an index column on
your data so then we use capacitor
capacitor runs tasks it's like a job
scheduler runs tasks and does work on
your data so we're going to use
capacitor tasks to do all the automation
steps of this workflow the four steps
there this is the second and third steps
are the ones that autumn automated
Brittany's capacitor to run those tasks
for us and evaluating service problems
with our models
and then third we can use Kona grass to
inspect the models just visually just
look at them that the third step they're
in the steps and yeah okay so here's a
graph hopefully it looks horrible to you
because it is horrible this is a graph
of all 400 repos and they're stars very
useful
I have great insights on this date I
mean you can pick out a few things right
like you can see that they're like three
projects that are way high above
everyone else you can see that some
exhibit is really sharp
like growth periods so like basically
vertical and then and then kind of just
have like linear or exponential growth
after that and but for the most part
yeah I'm not going to glean a whole lot
from that and you could go look at it
one by one but that'd take all day so
not very helpful of a graph but there it
is okay so step one we need to create
some tasks and capacitor to do our
evaluation steps so our plan here is to
create three tasks that do the model and
forecast the data to open we're going to
label it's like baseline models that are
really really simple forecasting models
and by simple I mean the mean one
literally takes the mean of the data and
says that's what the future value is
going to be is the current mean
so very very simple model but it
actually print turns out to be quite
useful later for just sanity checking
our models and then the other one is an
exponential smoothing or also known as
like whole winters you take it's a
recursive algorithm where you take the
current past history state and you build
up on it and you can predict out future
one it's pretty straight forward not
very complex
not knowing is complex for example the
profit model and that allows us another
baseline just hey make sure that things
are within within tolerance okay so then
we have our profit model so capacitor is
a system and I'll talk a little bit
about how it works in a second but the
profit model is written in Python and
our capacitors not run in Python is
there anything go if you care and so how
do we talk to it well faster has a
plug-in system UDS user-defined
functions and so we can just call out
Python code and run the profit model
from there
and it's efficient uses protocol buffers
for the data transfer eccentric setter
and okay so we have these three tasks
and these are actually task templates
meaning that we just we set up a
template for the mean task the whole
winters task and the profit task and
then we instantiate one of those tasks
for each of the github repos that we
have so we have roughly you know 1200
tax and the reason why we're doing all
these different tasks that sounds like
wow 1200 tasks why am i managing so many
when I only had 400 to start with why do
you know why we're blowing up the reason
is it gives us the ability to set
different parameters per task per repo
and it doesn't end up being a difficult
thing to manage because you don't touch
into the tasks unless they have issues
and then you just can treat them so
again the task is allows you to have
custom parameters per model which we'll
see in a second is useful okay so that's
step one
I just used a good new parallel a little
CLI command there and just said boom
define all these tasks duck and then the
way capacitor does the the template
system is any updates to the template
updates the rest of the tasks so you
don't end up ever really interacting
this tests after you define okay so BAM
here's some code probably looks really
unfamiliar to you just definitely not
Python and yeah let me tell you what
this is so who here was at the DAC
tutorial yesterday okay so a small stash
okay so so the way - does their
computation model is they model the data
as a dag directed acyclic graph
capacitor is the same thing they take
the data that you know the pipeline like
first you're going to sum the data then
you're going to take the mean and
they're going to do whatever and they
build this dag which is a pipeline of
the data flow of your data capacitor is
the same thing and it executes to the
stack based on the data the time series
data that's flowing through it the way
you describe your dag is through a DSL
inside a fastener called tick script
simple and this is what you're looking
at right here so the idea here is that
each of these pipe characters and the
act character act just means it's UDS
basically think of it as a pipe
character each of these pipes characters
represent an edge and
and that graph where data is transferred
from note to note and then the note
itself is like what are we going to do
at that step in the graph okay so here
we're querying the data out of the
database so we're going to select the
value we're getting a little bit of
weird formatting on that there's
supposed to be a space between from and
source there and between where and
projects but you get the idea it's equal
like this is pseudocode anyway so don't
expect this to actually run there's a
little bit of boilerplate above and
below that I just made it for brevity
and the videos we select our data we
grab it over a certain historical amount
of time and then we do it every so often
so these tasks run continuously they're
always scheduled and they just run
continuously so that this is just a
process that's online and money let me
group by instead of grouped by
dimensions in this case it's the project
so we're going to select all the data
we're going to group it by our list of
projects and then we're going to shove
it into the profit algorithm which this
basically except calls out to the UDF
and run this code so the profit
algorithm has a couple of properties
that you can pass in that I've
abstracted here to the US we you tell it
you give it a bunch of historical data
and then you say how far in the future
should I predict values and so that's
what this little bit here is as we say
you know half are we've got a parameter
to this entire script that's how far we
should forecast and then we've got an
interval for data points we divide them
that's a count of how many periods into
the future we should forecast then the
change point prior scale the talk
earlier today talks about using Bayesian
inference to detect change points the
profit algorithm uses a similar method
to find change points in these data and
flection points and growth and so you
can give it this kind of this value from
0 to 1 that says how how aggressively
should you look for change points and so
you can pass that in and then the profit
algorithm also returns a confidence
interval with and so you can tell it you
know another one again a value between 0
and 1 typically like 80 or 90 percent in
a confidence interval and you can say
how big you want those conferences to be
okay so there's our template we can
instantiate that 400 times and give it
different values but by default we'll
just give all 400 the same default
values and
works out the most of them okay so step
two we need to evaluate these models we
need to do so and a you know we need to
do it for all the historical data we
have and for each of the different
models right so we've got the different
projects and the different models the
mean to hold and the profit models and
so this is just a simple
single-tasking capacitor where we group
the data both by the project dimension
and the model dimension and then we
compare that data with so obviously
we'll hold out some of the data right so
we we pass it in the first year data we
have it predict out a little bit of time
and then we go look at that little bit
of time and we see how well it did right
we compute the error metric and again
here we are we're talking about the mean
absolute percentage error we're grabbing
that the map metric okay so here's the
task that computes that one so it's
really simple we've got our source data
and our forecasted data
we join them together and they're
already grouped by projects and models
so we join them on the models or on the
project dimension then we compute the
difference and then divide by the
current value and in this case we don't
have problems running the values of zero
because there's always at least one star
or the data doesn't exist and so we
never have a divide by zero issue and we
get a percentage error there but then we
want the mean percentage error so then
we just sum up and count all of the
different errors in that window of time
that we were given and we bring those
back together and compute the mean and
then BAM we've got our mates value and
we write that back to the database so
now we have a database that has the
source data a database that has the
forecasted data and then a database that
has the errors and all of those are over
time and as a dimension so we can track
those over time okay so step three is we
need to service the problematic models
this is really easy we now have the data
sitting in a database it's just a simple
select query just go get me so we're
talking about air so go get me the top
10 projects that have really high air
dot and then we say you know over the
recent data where the models profit
our worst performers if you want you can
do the inverse and you can get your best
performing models and really simple
you've got a set of all your models and
their errors over time in the database
you can just query any backup so you can
even go a step further than just
querying them and putting a table you
can plot a distribution of these so with
the distribution what I'm plotting here
is the the accuracy so the x-axis oh
yeah the x-axis here is the percentage
error as a log and then the y-axis is
just the normalized histogram
distribution so you can see that the me
model here in red and it has like a
point didn't do so great but overall the
errors like you know somewhere between
point zero one and point one so you know
one percent in ten percent so that's not
great but it gives you a good baseline
right so then the whole pointers model
actually has this nice slope over here
where and get some that are a lot better
than the mean model but overall still
not that much better than the mean model
in fact in some cases that's quite a bit
worse but still somewhere between 1
percent tempers and air on the whole
winters model so then we have the profit
model which on the whole actually gets a
lot more of its distributions down there
towards the smaller errors it's got some
that are really bad like this guy's got
two hundred fifty percent error I just
totally blew it out the model default
values were just horrible and didn't
work very well so hey that's our problem
guy these are gonna be the first one
that comes back on that select statement
and we're going to go fix it okay so
here's a graph of how you would fix that
model little dark bull we make it work
okay so the top data is both the raw
data plotted with the predicted values
for all three models and then this graph
is the the air being plotted and you can
you can see over there the scale is like
hundreds of percent of air and this is
the this blue line is the profit model
think I just blew out I got a ton of air
and it predicts so drastically that the
growth curve of this entire project just
looks flat in comparison so this model
just horribly predicted the data and
then I just kind of shut it down here
this is for an LP trace which is like a
s trace for Python type
thing and so we've got this table here I
only show the first entry but you've got
a table here of all 10 entries that are
the worst performers and this is the guy
that's on the top and we've selected him
and reviewing that projects data so
we've got a problem
we've visually inspected the data we
understand how it's broken so how do we
fix it okay so the Facebook profit gives
the simple guidelines and the whole
point of all of this setup and putting
this all together so that you have a
very simple checklist of three things
three questions you can ask yourself and
then proposed solutions so that the
process here is really quick and simple
so first question does the model have
large errors compared to the baseline
models and that one it was like yeah
definitely that was the issue
we'll go look back in a second and so so
maybe the problem models misconfigured
update the model so then we just know
that hey the problem model has that
parameters let's fix it another
possibility was that all the models went
bad so even the simple whole winter is
miscible mean model went bad well in
that case it's likely that there's some
outlier in the data just throwing all
the models off go find it remove it
right that's something it's really
simple to do all right third case the
errors were historically good like
they're historico lis very low but they
just recently spiked okay well maybe
that just means that we had a change and
the underlying process of this data and
we just need to go set that as a change
point the profit algorithm will auto
detect those change points but you can
also manually specify them so you can
say hey something happened in the data
that's different now think of it
differently manually here's the time it
changed and so you kind of get these
three and there may be other edge cases
right this is going to cover a very wide
breadth of the different ways that your
forecasting can fail and then you can
update right so we look back real quick
on the mean and hole winters models have
very small errors and they basically
follow the raw data which is in red so
the profit models the only one having
the issue so that means we're definitely
here in case one where the profit model
is the one that's misconfigured and we
need to update it so I went in I booked
at this one it also
a very small amount of data this project
started October of last year so it
doesn't have a long history to predict
it and so that was my hypothesis for why
it was getting messed up and you can you
can clearly see that it is thinking
there's really drastic change points and
really over predicting here so that that
initial parameter called the change
points prior scale I just pulled that
down nope you are not allowed to be as
flexible in deciding where the change
points are let's just pull that down
okay so pull it down here's the updated
model BAM table model still isn't great
but at least it's not 250 percent error
right now we're down to like 5 percent
and that was a 10 second change and then
I just kicked off the task to rerun the
model and that took another 30 seconds
and bam we fixed this one our list of
worst performers now has a new guy who's
sitting at 7% so now we know that our
max worst performers at 7% err still not
great but it's not 250%
and we can now go tackle that one and
and that you know I don't going to take
out our minute or two hopefully right so
that's kind of the general idea is to
invent it up and come back to step one
here is to start with a bunch of data
model at all compared to baselines
compare it to whatever metric you want
the mean absolute percentage error into
the NRS and evaluate those dozens of
values find the ones or you can even do
multiple if you wanted you could have
multiple graphs down here that's not
just the MAPE value but you could you
could do multiple of them and then you
just get this simple workflow where
you've got a table of really bad foreign
models you iterate on them and you fix
them and then you can keep your upper
bound on your worst performers law and
keep it down and then you don't end up
spending a ton of time managing these
and then you can trust that the rest of
your models are doing really well so
here's the final distribution now of the
profit model the whole winters one's a
mean one stayed the same so I didn't
regret to let it change those and that
that point that was way out here at 2
and 50% he's gone he's back down in the
middle somewhere and so it'd be nice to
take off anybody above 10% anywhere near
close that just shove them back down
but I didn't spend the time to actually
do that the but you can now start
pushing your distribution down okay so
so learnings and and we're at here so we
have used a tic-tac the database class
or engine in the visualization engine
part of my screenshots are actually from
something from graph on ax just because
I was messing with stuff there so if
you're familiar with katana or
chronographs very similar and some of my
screenshots probably recognize from
Ravana but anyway that doesn't matter
use a visualization engine and was able
to go there so forecasting is scale is
about reducing the cost per forecast
making that overhead just go way down so
they don't have to worry about it and
then and then you can do that by
creating a simple workflow with good
tooling that enables the analyst to not
have to worry about the complexities of
deploying or running the model or
anything like that
and so that's what the tick tack
provides is it's this platform on which
you can run many many models and you can
track and rate those models over time
watch how they're performing and then
surface those problems so there's also a
couple of really cool extensions here
capacitor actually has its origins and
DevOps meaning that it it was first
built as an alerting platform so I get
they're running on two servers the CPU
spikes alert me that the the CPU spike
which means that capacitor has built
into it all these systems and tools to
be able to alert you proactively about
issues right so what that means now is
you don't have to actually even go to
Agri fauna or cronograph dashboard to
look at them if one of your model starts
to go haywire you just get paged on your
phone and then you go look at it and
then you don't spend your day worrying
about this thing if you're if you if
you're getting silenced things are good
if you hear something you go look at it
and and then you can and then it can
also integrate in the other side of
things where it can for example we have
talked in this from before about using
kubernetes to scale at a large system
capacitor conductor kubernetes and it
can scale out on your pods etc etc and
it auto scaling based on based on these
metrics so if you've noticed so if
you're forecasting your data you could
forecast your utilization on your system
and auto scale and head of demand
instead of reactive to meant you could
proactively auto scale and that's where
the power of this of the tic-tac really
comes in is it's got these composable
bits where it's got nice decomposed
products the four different products
that interact together to collect store
visualize and process your data and then
they enter and they integrated with so
many different systems that you can put
in this big picture solution and on one
hand you can use it to analyze and
ensure that your models are staying
active and staying staying accurate and
then you can in the same system then go
take proactive action on those models
and so um here's some resources from
from a talk today the link is awesome
list link to get a profit paper and
implicator comm just to see more about
fixed active learn about it and that's
what happy today thank you questions yes
point said set or repeat the first part
say the equation for the growth
seasonality and holidays
I think talked about the change points
that it detected it and got off by 250%
how does it actually like predict the
graph and then secondly how much data do
you need to start using something like
this yeah
so yeah kind of skipped that part so
profit has that simple general out of
term that's like the girls turn the
seasonal term in the holiday term and
add them together and it just does an
optimization LG BFS is the acronym I
don't remember a stop Manuel that stands
for but it's it takes the data and it
fits using that optimization prop that
they can handle constraints and things
and it just fits the data to those
parameters so look at the Facebook
profit paper there's a ton of math
behind it kind of skipped over that
wasn't the important part is in the
algorithm by time that's pretty quick
doesn't need a ton of data so I only
have a data point per day for this stars
data and so and that one that was short
so it's like four months so you know
hundreds of in a couple hundred points
not not too many and and it can even
predict less if you're trying to predict
out less time into the future okay thank
you other questions
yes thank you my question was that does
the profit model learn across the trend
lines of time series data is like trying
to learn if one awesome project was
similar to another and predict the time
series according to that or is it just
for it was just per single series so
there's no like cross correlations or
anything okay yep I mean you can do that
in something like the tick stack it can
start doing those correlations for you
but the profit algorithm itself is
simply about time series forecasting for
single theories okay but it's faster you
can run off through just a question on
capacitor is it is it like tightly
integrated into influx DV or is it like
a separate processing framework yeah the
capacitor is a separate process and it
so it's tightly integrated with input to
be and that it can consume in flux DV
but it can also consume data from other
sources as well and so it just has an
API where you write data to it because
it's stream processing or it can go
query the data and so either way you
want to do it it can stream the data
live to it or you can just have a query
back kind of in flux to be but it can
run independent of influx to be if you
want it to you know that kind of thing
so the question was kind of do
aggregations as well and absolutely yeah
so I showed you some of the more complex
features of capacitor where it can
actually call out to a Python mod model
for the profit algorithm but it can do a
lot of basic things to just like
simplify auditions by dimension and time
and these kinds of things
well thank you very much
[Applause]